Animated films like Bambi
Frozen and up often allude to a character death that takes place off screen other children's movies took things a step further by actually showing
A death on the screen some of these horrific scenes would be hard to handle in live-action films never mind animated hits
Watch and see various tragic deaths murders and hangings all in animated form when it's an accident. They call it manslaughter
Before you watch grab a tissue and then click Subscribe
You'll join the notification squad and be the first to know of new content also
Can you guess which movie is represented by these emoji stay tuned at the end to find out?
You want me to be the bad guy? Fine. Now I'm the bad guy.
Tangled
let's face it Mother Gothel had it coming she kidnapped Rapunzel as a baby forced her to live a majority of her life in a
tower and stole the magic in her hair
So she could live eternally there was really no other option for the evil witch except death although her demise was expected
No
One knew it could be as gruesome as it was as Flynn sits in pain with a mortal wound he chops all of Rapunzel's magical
Hair off this also meant that Mother Gothel lost all the magic. She used to stay young right before our very eyes
We saw her wither away to skin and bone
But even that wasn't enough as she runs around and her body literally dies by the second the mischievous
chameleon Pascal puts up a chunk of hair to trick mother Gothel and send her flying out the tower window this would have been a
Great time to cut away
But we see her continue to deteriorate
As she falls a cut to the wide shot shows just how far she's falling down to her grassy grave by the time
She reaches the bottom her old body's nothing but rags and dust. yikes!
rare form of monster known as...
dolmas
Monster house
From the trailers and preview clips the movie Monster House looked like a fun
Animated adventure about a crazy house that came alive once people saw the film and learned about the houses backstory
They realized the movie is a lot deeper than they realized. In Monster House the back story involves a lady named Constance
Who's heavily overweight and made into the laughingstock of a touring circus?
Then she meets nebbercracker the to fall in love and start to build their dream home together
Just when you think Constance will be happy her gruesome death scene takes place
standing above the open basement foundation of the
construction site
Constant loses her balance and falls far down into the hole as she fell her arm pulled on a lever releasing gallons of wet cement
That poured over her dead body as soon as it landed.
The scene is pretty crazy to watch
But it only gets worse when the children
exploring the house see her buried corpse in the form of cement and then later see the
Skeleton that has been trapped underneath it for all these years. The monster house may seem mean and evil
But viewers look at it with a whole different perspective once they learn the sad truth about what made it haunted
Ola, did you hear about the latest addition to our family? The richest Espanyol is the perfect place for all you native Spanish speakers out
There don't speak Spanish? no problem come on over. This is the perfect place to practice
Amazing facts interesting people and funny pictures. Check out the richest espanol today
Needless to say we're all shocked and saddened are the news of a de contrôle...
Green Lantern Emerald Knights. Green Lantern may not have found success on the big screen
But that hasn't stopped DC's animated universe from creating a number of animated hits featuring the character. In
2011 DC released the
Straight-to-video release of Green Lantern Emerald Knights, the film is an anthology of stories that captures the spirit of the Green Lantern
Universe through a variety of tales and characters. There's one character
You shouldn't get too attached to though and her name is Arcadian trawl or jacket
The Green Lantern character appears briefly in the film before she's killed and probably the worst way possible
My god...
While flying trawl is pursued by a collection of shadow demons while she's able to fight them off at first the battle becomes too
Overwhelming without any help, this is when the shadow demons strike
They slice off her legs than her hands
And then decapitate her the animation actually shows her lifeless head floating through space did we mention that this movie only has a PG rating?
The scene looks like something out of saw and the pure agony. She goes through is pretty tough to watch
*Gun sound made by Tarzan*
Men like you!
Tarzan
Tarzan never had it easy in the jungle once raised by gorillas you was always being treated unfairly
For being different as Tarzan got older
He was forced to defend his family from predatory animals if things weren't bad enough
Tarzan had to deal with Clayton and the massive gun he totes around the war between
Clayton and Tarzan became a serious one where only one person could survive
Fighting among the trees Clayton was clearly out of his league compared to the more experienced Tarzan.
This was especially true when Clayton became tangled up in a collection of vines
Tarzan saw Clayton's impending doom and tried to help him,
But it was too late
Clayton dropped to his death and hung by the vines in the middle of the jungle with a few flashes of lightning we can see
Clayton's dead body dangling from the vines as a somber tarzan catches his breath. an
Animated hanging is pretty tough to take and very revealing even if it was just the shadows being shown
Littlefoot: Mother?
Littlefoot's Mother: Run run!
The Land Before Time
There's so many different animated films where one or more of the parents have died or are missing from the picture
While that's sad enough as it is it's nothing compared to seeing the actual parental death in animated form
this is what the Land Before Time did and one of the saddest animated scenes put to print early on in the movie Littlefoot and
His friend Sara encounter the hungry carnivore nicknamed Sharptooth Sharptooth nearly eats the little dinosaurs before
littlefoot's mother steps in to save the day the battle
Obviously took its toll on littlefoot's mother as she can no longer continue the journey to the Great Valley
As she slowly dies in the pouring rain Littlefoot can't quite comprehend. What's going on
His mother is still able to give Littlefoot plenty of words of wisdom as she lies there and takes her last breath the movie brilliantly
Stays on the shot for longer than you'd expect
Really taking in the emotional impact of death and losing a loved one
It doesn't make the sad scene any easier to watch
Littlefoot's journey continues in ten plus sequels to the film where he carries on the spirit and drive his mother gave him during her last
moments
Evangeine likes that, too
The Princess and the Frog
for Disney's 2009 film The Princess and the Frog
we're introduced to a whimsical cast of characters one of these characters is Rey a
Firefly with an old soul and dreams of meeting the love of his life who lives up in the stars
Rey is crucial to revealing the fake Naveen during a thrilling scene in the film where he tears off a
Magical necklace charm gives it to Tiana and unfortunately Rey's small size gets the best of him as dr. Facili knocks him down
That's not enough for the cruel, man
Though as he takes one step with his boot and crushes Rey underneath it in a truly devastating
scene
Luis manages to find Rey barely clinging to life and runs him to Tiana and Naveen as quick as he can has raised light sputters
In and out he takes his last dying breaths and looks up at the stars one last time as he looks forward to reuniting with
Evangeline who knew that a dead bug can make you feel so many
Emotions to help ease the pain Rey is shown in a spiritual form near the end of the film
I'm done for Wilbur
In a while I'll be dead.
Charlotte's Web a
Spiders work is never finished
And that's truly the case for Charlotte and the classic animation Charlotte's Web the story
Showcases the unlikely friendship between a pig named Wilbur and a spider willing to do anything to help keep the pig from being slaughtered
Charlotte spends endless nights weaving
Incredible webs that spell words including some Pig and humble those webs help spare Wilbur's life and prevent him from becoming a plate of bacon
Or ham by the time the collection of farm animals goes to the local carnival Charlotte is pretty worn out
And it's obvious what will happen next
After spinning a web of eggs Charlotte says her goodbyes to Wilbur and quietly dies as she backs away
The final shot of her death scene shows a few strains of spiderweb blowing in the distance
somehow animators have made a spider feel sympathetic when many people have a fear of the eight-legged creatures Ellie Charlotte's legacy lived on with the
Birth of five hundred and fourteen children out of all of them three decided to stay on the farm where Wilbur lives
This created a bittersweet moment in the film. That's pretty hard to have a happy ending with
Joy: Thats right your theme song! Who's your friend who likes to play? Bing Bong:
Bing Bong, Bing Bong
Both:His rocket makes you yell "Hooray!"
Bing Bong Bing Bon!~
Inside out the majority of the Pixar film inside out takes place inside the mind of an 11 year old girl named Riley
It's there where we're introduced to all types of unique characters including anger fear joy and sadness as joy and sadness go on their adventure
Through the brain of a young girl they also come across the character of bing-bong bing-bong was a whimsical
Imaginary friend Riley made up when she was younger as she's aged the memory of Bing bong
Isn't as strong as it used to be Bing bong ends up being stuck in Riley's memory dump with joy the characters attempt to escape
But the weight is too much to get out of the pit
This is when Bing bong decides to sacrifice himself by jumping out of the wagon Bing bong knows his fate now
And he slowly disappears from the screen lost forever this death scene may only represent an imaginary friend
But it can hit hard for a lot of viewers this
Represents the loss of innocence the end of childhood and everything that goes away when you get older. We'll miss you Bing bong
*Evil laughing* (Something) You shall DIE!
The Black Cauldron
When people talk about the best Disney Villains names like Jafar Ursula and Captain Hook may come up
Well none of them compared to the purely evil Horned King from the Black Cauldron
The dark Disney fantasy features the Horned King as the main villain
And he's downright scary with glowing red eyes horns and antlers the evil character is enough to give children nightmares for days
Even his gruesome death scene in the Black Cauldron is scary as the Horned King
Attempts to send a young boy into the cauldron of doom. He's the one who gets sent inside
This is when Disney really pushed their limits with death scenes for the dramatic sequence
The skin is violently torn off the Horned Kings body
He becomes engulfed in flames and blood spins around him as his corpse gets burned alive the whole scene goes on for several
seconds without any
cutaways to minimize the craziness of the shots the whole thing looked like the
climactic scenes of Raiders of the Lost Ark when all of the Nazis burned to death
It's what the Horned King deserved in the end, but we're not quite sure if we needed to see it all
Simba: dad? Mufasa: hm? Simba: were pals right? Mufasa: Right.
and we'll always be together right?
The Lion King the Lion King is one of the most emotional films that Disney has ever put out the drama
betrayal and devastating scenes all stem from Mufasa is tragic death early in the film after
Heroically saving Simba from a stampede he tries to escape the carnage himself and climb up the edge of a cliff
This is when scar reveals his true colors
He closeted mufasa's paws and sends him to his death below
Simba watched on in horror as his father plummeted down even though
It was a large fall into a stampede of animals the film gave us a little
Hope you would survive after cutting back to his body
Shortly after what makes the death scene even harder to watch is the fact that Simba nudges his dad trying to awaken the dead lion.
With no answer Simba has nothing to do but tuck in underneath the arm of his dead dad for one last touch of comfort
Mufasa is lifeless corpse was on screen for way longer than anyone expected making his death even harder to handle
Sadness quickly turns to anger as scar approaches and pins the blame for mufasa's death directly on Simba
Thankfully Simba avenges his father's death and saves the pride by the end of the movie
And there you have it what animated death? Do you think was the most graphic are there? Any we missed?
What's the saddest animated death scene? let us know in the comments section below don't forget to like this video share it and subscribe!
To Screen Rant on YouTube, so you can stay up to date with our awesome videos and the answer to the emoji quiz is!
*Outro*